haití vive una crisis social política
sanitaria y económica que se agudizó con
el asesinato del presidente lleven el
maíz y con la pobreza estructural que se
espera para el país ahora que es
golpeado por este terremoto
buenos días y bueno lo que se espera
para el país es imprevisible porque la
crisis se ha a homex se ha llegado tan
grave que uno no puede no puede predecir
qué se puede y qué va a pasar primero
estaban en la crisis es una crisis
institucional
constitucional también porque con la
muerte de jóvenes
no había cargos constitucionales que
podrían reemplazarlo y las instituciones
tampoco funcionaban y hoy
aquí está afectado por un terremoto y en
el cono sur que
digamos toda la zona sur del país que
está pasando estemos en este momento
sufriendo esta crisis se va empeorando
la situación en esta zona porque está
esta zona ya era una zona muy afectada
por toda la crisis en el país el hambre
se va a aumentar la condición de
desempleo en las cifras del desempleo se
va a aumentar y en todo todo va a ir
aumentando para mal para el mal del país
y para el mal y sus gentes de nuestros
compatriotas que están allá que están su
piel
edison como cubrir las numerosas
deficiencias del estado ahora con esta
tragedia
el estado tenemos un estado ausente
tenemos un estado que también por ser un
estado de un país calificaron como
neocolonia
de los países imperialistas el estado no
trabajaba digamos en los mejores tiempos
y para cubrirlo esperando partir del
estado no no va a pasar nada lo que se
está viendo en las imágenes es lo que
por lo menos una forma de cubrir los
decadencia la eficiencia del estado
gente es el pueblo poniéndose la mano en
las piedras centrándose en los escombros
para sacar a sus seres queridos queridos
familiares que están en el distinto
otros países viendo cómo ayudar
salir de esto para que sea hacer un
aporte más más útil al país es
necesitamos una solidaridad una
solidaridad plena con respecto a la
autoridad y determinación de este pueblo
con respecto a lo que quiere este pueblo
lo que vengan a dar a hacer lo mismo que
pasó en los miles porque
hace 11 años ya que pasó el terremoto
y bueno las estructuras siguen lo mismo
siguen iguales symbian iguales y no
queremos que volvemos volver a esto que
la comunidad internacional por ejemplo
se toma la en el encargo todo todo lo
que es la la gestión el manejo de la
crisis y al final no se ve nada y
precisamente hablando de esto ya varios
países anunciaron su intención de
socorrer a haití pero qué garantías hay
de que no se repita lo ocurrido en 2010
cuando las ayudas no se vieron
reflejadas en la reconstrucción de la
isla luego del terremoto
no hay ninguna gran realmente no hay
porque ya lo hemos vivido lo hemos
vivido con con el terremoto esta zona
que está afectada en 2016 fue afectado
por uno con el huracán matthew también
la comunidad internacional había dicho
que va a apoyar pero no sirve en exceder
porque lo que necesitamos lo que
necesita el pueblo es una una ayuda que
permite el desarrollo que permite a
atacar la infraestructura del país y no
hay ninguna garantía el estado no
funciona el estado que primero debería
garantizar que estas raza eficiente que
no vuelve a pasar lo que está pasando lo
que ha pasado en 2010 este estado no
está funcional no está no no está
trabajando por ejemplo hay un corte
entre el sur y el resto del país sólo
por una zona que se llama matizan donde
bandas armadas se empujándolo este lugar
y nos dejan pasar y el estado de recién
ayer a las siete a las cinco o seis de
la tarde de haití estaban tratando de
llegar
al sur y no solamente me cae quieres una
en la ciudad de más afectada pero
también al sur west england el seremi
donde también son zonas muy alejadas
ya terrestre no se puede ir por ahí
las estructuras hay un cuarto arias
también fueron afectadas